hey guys I'm Dena Takuya and we're going
to be taking a look at five times the US
has interfered in foreign elections
including cia-backed coos and a whole
lot of money after the WikiLeaks release
of her campaign emails Hillary Clinton
accused Russia of trying to interfere in
the u.s. presidential election this has
come from the highest levels of the
Russian government clearly from Putin
himself in an effort as seventeen of our
intelligence agencies have confirmed to
influence our election but the US isn't
exactly one to talk about interfering in
foreign elections because it has a long
history of doing just that in 2014
Afghans went to the polls but the
results of the election were
inconclusive and there were widespread
claims of fraud so the u.s. stepped in
and negotiated a power-sharing agreement
which would place a chef Lenny who the
u.s. supported as president and his
opponent Abdullah Abdullah was given an
entirely new job the u.s. created called
chief executive officer and that wasn't
the first time the US had a hand in
Afghanistan's elections the u.s. already
had interfered in the 2009 elections
which were marred by accusations of
fraud low voter turnout and violence and
before Afghanistan there was Honduras in
2009 the democratically elected Honduran
President Manuel Zelaya was ousted in a
coup d'état led by the military
officially President Obama said the u.s.
opposed the coup but Hillary Clinton who
was Secretary of State at the time
admitted in her book hard choices that
she pushed for elections to occur
quickly after the coup to quote render
the question of zalaya moot so he
couldn't return to power that's been
really bad for Honduras where violence
has skyrocketed since the coup for some
countries US involvement is the rule not
the exception like in Haiti in 2015 the
u.s. provided money to fund elections
which had no clear winner and run ups
have since been postponed several times
in Washington supported the flawed
election of 2010 to keep Michelle sweet
Micky Martelli on the ballot after he
lost in the first round and it helped
fund the 2009 elections that excluded
Haiti's major political parties oh and
the US backed the 2004 coup that deposed
jean-bertrand Aristide Haiti's first
democratically elected president but
don't think that getting involved in
foreign elections is a new
for the u.s. back in 1953 in Iran the
CIA directed the military coup that
overthrew democratically elected Prime
Minister Mohammad Mosaddegh and
installed the Shah the u.s. claimed that
supporting the Shah was part of the cold
war-era fight against communism but the
real reason had more to do with making
sure American and British companies
continue to access Iran's oil the Shah
was ultimately overthrown by the Iranian
Revolution
she didn't work out too well for the
u.s. in the end but Iran isn't the only
time the US has rigged elections to
protect its economic interests in 1954
Washington backed the overthrow of
Guatemalan president ha Cabo uh turbines
they wanted to keep him from passing
laws that would protect the rights of
Guatemalan farmers over foreign
companies like the American owned United
Fruit Company the right-wing leaders a
CIA back to replace our bends led brutal
dictatorships that left the country in
poverty all those examples are just a
handful of times the US has influenced
elections abroad to protect its own
interests it doesn't make it okay but
how surprising is it that other
countries might want to do the same
thing to the US in the case of Haiti
elections are just one of the many ways
US involvement has been harmful if you
want to learn more check out our video
on how the US has long failed Haiti